Allah Allah ortaokul lise yılları
boyunca ileride yapma ihtimalim olduğuna
inandığım iki önemli konuşmayı kafanda
tasarlayıp duruyordum Bunlardan biri
iohs Karlarda teşekkür konuşması bu
var Yani bu doğru basit bir konuşma gibi
dursa da doğru stratejik hamleleri
atmadığını zaman sizleri tam olarak
Vezir oldum dediğiniz noktada rezil
rüsva edebilecek bir konuşmadır kendisi
çünkü hani süreyi doğru kullanabilecek
miyim Ne bileyim işte dedim teşekkür de
anneyi babayı katacak mıymış şimdi
onlardan bahsedersen Dayı tarafın
bozulur mu gibi gibi ya 13 yaşında
yaşadığım bu dehlizlerin içerisinde en
sonunda kendi kendime dedim Yok a Bu
böyle olmayacak Nitekim ben oturdum ve
kendime bir acil durum Oscar konuşması
yazdım
Ha bir de konuşmaya hazırladım ettim
Aynı günün akşamında bütün aileyi evin
salonunda topladım geçtim kar sana açtım
ciddi ciddi Oscar teşekkür konuşmalı
yaptım dayım döndü bana dedi ki oğlan
kafayı yemiş
bir ara dedim ki aileyik atmayacağız biz
bu işe bir diğer önemli konuşmada
özellikle lise yıllarında internetten
açık açıp sardığım TED konuşmaları ydı
Çünkü o hani bu işleri Los Işıklı
sahnede anlatılanlar o konuşmacılar plan
bana o kadar havalı geliyordu ki kendi
kendine iyi onları izleyebilir ve Onu
anlıyorum düzgün Sen de çıkacaksın
buraya veya hani diyordum ki ben
Muhtemelen zaten yıllar sonra TL falan
çıkarsam o zaman hani Muhtemelen işte
Kara deliklerin uzay-zaman bükülmesinin
etkileri ya da ne bileyim moleküler
transportasyon da be negatif değerlerin
ölçülüp ölçüm denemediği yani keser sapı
gibi konulardan bahseden ben o sahneyi
öttürürüm orada da diyordum
la la Kinder dostlar
o o
bu tarihler Bizi bugüne getirdiğinde
sizlere be Kırşehir'de yaşayan 46
yaşında İki çocuk annesi Neriman ve
ve İstanbul'da yaşayan 22 yaşında moda
tasarım öğrencisi Eren'in kindo doğru
oranlarda sulandırılarak birbirine
karıştırılmasından Türkiye'de yaşayan
her bir bireyi nasıl elde
edebileceğimizi anlatacağım ben
mı böyle bir yetim olduğunu bundan
Yaklaşık dört sene önce Nisan ayında bir
akşam evde otururken arkadaşlarımla
dalga geçmek için yaptığım videoları
internete yüklemeye karar verdiğimde
fark etmeye başladım ve tam olarak bu
kararımdan 10 dakika sonra falan da
sizlerin şu anda var böyle tipler olarak
bildiğiniz Instagram sayfası bomboş ve
her şey Olmaya hazır bir şekilde
karşımda duruyordu o zamanlar o sayfayla
ilgili ne yapacağıma dair en ufak bir
fikrim yoktu
yok ama fikrim olan Kesin kararlı
olduğun teknik onu vardı o da ne kendimi
ne de bu hesabı fenomenler denen o
Tarikatı alet etmeyeceğim de adede
dostlar bugün bilet alıp gelmişsiniz
buraya bilmediğiniz şeyleri öğrenmeye
hakkınız var Bunlar tarikat abii
gerçekten Bunlar full şarja ve sayfa
yukarıya kaydırmaya tapıyor
ve her ayın belli bir günü ismini
veremeyeceğim bir yerde gizlice
buluşuyorlar danla Bilic önderliğinde
bu işte içeriye giriliyor içerde
cübbeler giyiliyor Instagram'da mavi tık
olmayanlar için Instagram sahibine
adaklar adanır your bakire koyunlar
kesiliyor onların kanı telefona
sürülüyor alma sürülüyor ezoterik bi tık
dansı var falan filan Bilmem ne Ama
Alice bahsettiğim ortamda gözünüzde şey
canlanması neowiz WhatsApp'taki ortam
canlanması Yani daha çok içeri girdiğini
anda o çakma balenciaga ayakkabıları
yanık plastiği kokuyor Anladın mı böyle
bir ortam var içerde
o ve herkes orada yani Game beri orada
makyajcısı orada anasının babasının
elinde olsa ilk fırsatlar edecekleri
geri zekalı çocukları orada
Ama artık lohusalıktan beyni şarampole
Yuvarlanmış youtuber anneler orada
Tabii ki Bence en tehlikelisi onlar ve
içerdiği gerçekten öyle bir ortam var ki
yani
Ama bu tarikatın Herbir üyesi o kadar
hakim ki her şeye yani Hani bi Proton
çarpıştır ıyor içeride yani dünyalar
kurtarılıyor böyle bir ciddiye alınmış
vaziyette her şey yani like ların
istatistikleri çıkartılıyor pozitif
yorumlar negatif yorumlar onlar
hesaplanıyor şunlar bunlar beni taraftan
biri gelmiş bana diyor ki abi diyor de
takipçilerine etkileşime giriyor musun
Bak en önemlisi oluyor orada bir tane
kız ağlıyor 300 takipçi gitti falan
Allah belanı versin Ne oluyor ya
Yok ya ben hiç bir başvuru belgesi
doldurmamız olmama rağmen karga tulumba
beni aralarına aldılar
bu veya kendi kendime diyorum ki yani
ya altı üstü bir tane video yapıyorsun
şuraya koyuyorsun bir tane fotoğraf
çekiyorsun oraya koyuyorsun altı saat
fondöten övüyorsun
yok yani
Ya bunlar nasıl bu kadar Cihan'ı devranı
değiştirecek bir hale gelebiliyor sizin
için Çünkü ben buna bir iş olarak
bakmıyorum Bu bir meslek olamaz Bana
göre yani Ama ki hiç o açıdan düşünmüyor
o kitleye atıyorum hani gerçekten
Ama bir gün Mark Zuckerberg in kafasının
bozuk olduğu bir güne denk gelsek ne
olacak Hani Instagram'da yanlışlıkla
basılmış bir hanımefendiye Dolayısıyla
karısıyla durumlar acı kahve ve liseden
arkadaşlar ayı Arkadaşlar bunu meyhaneye
götürmüş iç iç Oradan çıkışta Facebook
hep bu artır nerede lan Instagram'ı
kapatma düğmesi falan abi yapa bastığı
Instagram gitti gitti ne olacağız O
zaman ne kadar işsiz olacak Ne kadar
işsizlik artacak bütün dünyada ya
ya o yüzden bana göre bu bir iş olamaz
diyordu
O hep bugün böyle bir şey olursa ne
olacak biliyor musunuz şu olacak
arkadaşlar
ve Belki de bu gece yaptığım bütün
dualar kabul oldu Ee Belki de Allah çok
yalvardım Allah'ım dolu bana yardım et
bugün çok yağlardır niye hesabım geri
geldi hep yer Kardeşler iade ettiler
Murat abi seni bu kadar yardımsever
olduğunu bilmiyorduk hesabını sana göre
veriyoruz dedi lan lan Çok teşekkür
ederim Çok teşekkür ederim çok sağ olun
çocuklar Sağ ol Çok sağ ol gerçekten
yani
Allah bizi bu hallere düşürdüğünüz için
çok sağ ol yani yatağımda İşte bu
sebepten ötürü kendi kendime deli bir
ben böyle olmayacağım abi Böyle olmadı
bir yüzüm yok yani
bu ne olacak ya Tamam ben de insanlar
güldürebilmek için bir şeyler yapıyorum
ama açtım ben buna hiç gülmedim peki
Yani gülmeye bilirsin orası zaten benim
oyun alalım Ben böyle bakıyorum oraya Ya
neyi değiştirecek ki benim oraya koydum
Bir tane video birinin hayatını bilmem
dedim neyi değiştirecek
mı diye
mı böyle şımarıkça düşünceler içerisinde
O geçen günlerimden bir tanesinde bir
takipçimden bir mesaj at
ne diyordu ki Kıvanç Ağabey merhaba
Benim erkek kardeşim organ nakli
bekliyor biz bunun için aylardır
hastanedeyiz ve seni çok seviyor Senin
videolarına çok gülüyor Ben de normalde
tiyatro oyuncusuyum ama kardeşimin
yanında kalmam gerektiği için işte
burada yatılı olan ve hasta çocuklara
drama kursları veriyorum dersler
veriyorum falan filan senden dedi tek
bir şey rica edeceğim Lütfen dedi bizim
gibi organ nakli bekleyen o kadar fazla
insan var ki senden ricam dedi insanları
Bu konuda bilinçlendirecek bir tane
video yap abi dedi çünkü gerçekten çok
ihtiyacı var İnsanların bu bilinçlenmeye
dedi
mi Evet ya hakikaten Yani bir buçuk
milyon kişi olmuş orası Yani bişe kaba
dokunur da bir şey yapmanın yararlı
olabileceğini düşündüm ve gerçekten de
bir video yapmak üzere oturdum işte bir
şeyler yazıyorum insanları doğru sosyal
sorumluluk kuruluşuna yönler nasıl
yönlendiririm onu araştırıyorum ediyorum
derken bir hafta sonra falan bir mesaj
daha geldi ondan dedi ki Kıvanç abi
Müjdemi isterim bugün dedi kardeşime
organ nakli yapıldı dedi Biz çok
mutluyuz dedi Ne olursun senden rica
ediyorum su video yap dedi birileri
bilinç lensin ve dedi bizim yaşadığımız
mutluluğu başkalarında yaşayabilirsin ne
olursun dedi
var yani tamam artık ben bu video
yapıyorum yani videoyu çektim hazırladım
sosyal sorumluluk kuruluşuyla konuştu
ettim falan filan Akşama video
yükleyeceğim Slime bir mesaj daha geldi
ertesi günü
abone ol
ve Kıvanç abi de de biz bu günleri
kardeşimi kaybettik dedi
ben onu hasta yatağında bir tek sen
güldürebiliyor bunu sana çok teşekkür
ederiz de
iyi bir insan
bu ne kadar sert bir tokat yiyebilir s o
kadar sert bir Tokat yedim orada
bu ve sonrasında
Ben Kendi Kendime şunu farkettim
abone ol
de birilerine çıkıp birşeyleri
anlatabileceğin noktada bunun
ve etkileyici olması için illa moleküler
transportasyon da ki be negatif değeri
Ya da bilmem nesi olması gerekmiyor
var birilerinin mutlu olabilme
birilerini mutlu edebilmek
ve Bence bu dünyadaki yapılabilecek ya
da keşfedilecek her şeyden daha değerli
Teşekkür ederim ve ve Tam da bu sebepten
ötürü
ya Neriman ve Eren'in nasıl bir
karışımından meydana gelmişsiniz gelin
Bir tıkla milyonlara ulaşabildiğiniz o
dijital dünyamızda sizden tek bir şey
rica ediyorum 4 kilo fondöten övmek
yerine insanları birazcık daha mutlu
edebilecek şeyler paylaşın Çünkü ben CC
mutluluğa en muhtaç olduğumuz devirde
doğduk hepimizi ve o